dancing Oh has spent years working on
the hill and in the white house he was
the senior adviser to Mitt Romney and
Paul Ryan in the 2012 presidential
campaign good morning good morning
Charlie will talk about general Kelly
but first this story I mean can you
imagine what are the implications if in
fact the president and since you wrote
the well initial statement it sounds
like there's not a legal issue if he's
shaping a statement that's just
basically a pressing PR document so I
mean it's it's words problematic but
it's not a legal issue the question is I
think what many will wonder many
observers and potentially many
investigators like Bob Muller will
wonder is if he's so loose with what he
will say and so directly involved with
the process of potentially misleading
with a communications document does that
translate also over to what he will be
or has done in terms of communications
with investigators so that's where the
questions I think will come on
one other questions everybody has always
been asking who can say no to the
president right do we now have someone
who can say no to the president I think
we have someone who can say no to the
president the question is will the
president listen and it actually relates
directly to your previous question so
John Kelly is a master of discipline and
organization he's an organization man he
will bring discipline or at least try to
bring discipline and organization to
this White House and it sounds like that
is the agreement he got from President
Trump that he is in charge that there
will be a formal chain of command the
sole term walk-in privileges where you
know 10 15 members of the senior staff
can just walk into the Oval Office
whenever they want and be able to talk
to the president that's over if someone
wants to disseminate information to the
president if someone's to have a
conversation with the president that all
has to be coordinated through the chief
of staff by the way we talked about that
now like it's a foreign concept it's the
way it's always been done it's what
we've experienced in the last six months
has been an aberration so he's just
trying to restore what some might call
regular order the challenge here is
Trump has this network this sort of
rolodex of relationships
some of them family some of them just
friends all over the place that he's
constantly consulting with how does John
Kelly control that if the president's
children want to have a conversation
with the president outside of the White
House about some policy matter how does
the chief of staff control that if the
president on the weekend of Marlo go
wants to check in with friends and pick
their brain has the chief of staff
controlled
I think that gets complicated how does
the president say to the how does the
chief of staff say the president mr.
president you can't weigh in on your
son's statement right on a legal matter
right and when you get to what the
president's actually trying to get done
legislatively does the fact that John
Kelly while he has this distinguished
national security career doesn't have
legislative experience really hurt the
president in some way well no I think I
think he definitely helps for the phone
you need you need two inputs in order to
advance a policy agenda one you need
just basically organization and
discipline so over the last couple days
the president was attacking Mitch
McConnell on Twitter sort of like
baiting Mitch McConnell to to try to
move forward with health care parties
right so you don't go on if you want a
successful legislative affairs strategy
you don't go after the Senate majority
leader of your own party no less so so
if Kelly can rein in that just that
basic organization and discipline that
will help a lot but you also need people
around the president with serious policy
chops when it comes to governing the
White House is light on that right now
but I think Kelly can recruit that so I
think Kelly brings organization and
discipline if they can recruit policy
jobs and the organization discipline
holds meaning the president listens to
Kelly I think they can start moving
forward on on tax reform actually make
debut damn you're predicting hiring not
firing it's a yes yes